marie george buffet est l'invité ce soir
de preuves par 3 bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous à j moins 5 du premier tour
d'une élection présidentielle marquée
tout le monde le reconnaît par le
dynamisme de la campagne de votre
champion donc à jean luc mélenchon à
gauche et du front de gauche
troisième homme ou pas il n'y a plus
beaucoup à attendre en sera ça dimanche
non non il ya ici il ya beaucoup à faire
encore il ya beaucoup à faire pour
gagner pas beaucoup à attendre à en
savoir s'il sera le dernier
occuper toutes les heures c'est ce que
font tous les candidats
voilà on ne lève pas le pied mais après
la présidentielle marie george buffet il
y aura les législatives cruciales on le
sait pour le parti communiste vous êtes
député
et puis également la question de votre
participation au gouvernement en cas
d'élection de françois hollande sur
toutes ces questions vous répondrai tout
à l'heure à samir tounsi de l' agence
france-presse
et puis green tarnos de public sénat et
revisitera avec vous les belles années
que vous avez connu que ministre
ministre de la jeunesse et des sports ce
que vous auriez envie de recommencer
vous nous direz ça tout à l'heure pour
vous pour les communistes on peut le
dire d'abord les présidentielles se
suivent mais ne se ressemblent pas un
2012 n'est pas 2007 et vous avez bien
placé pour le savoir
et ben ouais je m'en félicite on a
retrouvé une dynamique avec le front de
gauche le parti communiste a initié
c'est moi même qui ai lancé cette idée
lorsque j'étais secrétaire national et
nous avons avec l'arrivée de jean luc et
la création du pass du parti de gauche
l'arrivée de la gauche unitaire avec
christian picquet qui avait quitté le
npa puis bien d'autres qui nous ont
rejoints nous avons maintenant créer une
alternative à gauche et on a changé la
donne album mêlant chant qui l'a
ressuscité silence et jean-luc fait une
très très belle campagne
il fait une campagne marquée par lev
l'espoir il fait de l'éducation
populaire ses dires il explique pourquoi
on est arrivé là les raisons de la crise
les solutions à y apporter les remèdes
c'est donc j'espère une pompe pas
vraiment de très haut niveau
et puis cette dynamique du front de
gauche tu te rends compte entre des
hommes et des femmes venus de
différentes origines à gauche et qui se
retrouvent et qu'il faut une campagne je
trouve très très forte
donc je les ai l'un des enjeux peut-être
sont en jeu c'est d'être le troisième
homme
dimanche devant marine le pen mais
d'abord il faut se dire qu'une campagne
n'est jamais terminé donc il faut pas se
mettre de plafond dans la tête avec le
troisième homme mourinho d'accord mais
il faut peut-être encore monter plus
haut il faut lui comme un croisement il
faut aller chercher il faut aller
chercher la gagne à gauche il a gagné le
gauche a passera par le plus haut score
du front de gauche
vous savez on voit bien que françois
hollande est à 27 28 29 sont les
sondages mais il tient un jour après
jour dans ces eaux là qu'est ce qui fait
que la gauche monte c'est la montée du
front de gauche en ce moment donc
françois hollande progresse aussi ce que
je veux dire parce que souvent on
interprète en dix ans le front de gauche
prendraient sur lectorat de france pour
les deux camps mais justement l'utilité
du vote front de gauche et je crois est
évidente pour jouer la gagne est donc
l'enjeu du troisième homme est ce que
finalement je vais peut être vous
choquer est ce que jean luc mélenchon et
marine le pen ne sont pas les deux
versants de la même exaspération sociale
oui ou choqué parce que nous avons nous
sommes pas sur les mêmes valeurs d'abord
non mais non c'est la même colère mais
la colère il faut bien sûr porter la
colère nous la portons nous pour
résister aux politiques libérales
premièrement madame le pen dans son
projet économique et sur les données
libéral et sur la vidéo logique libérale
deuxièmement si les noms se libéraliser
son programme ya aucune mesure qui va
dans le sens d'une mise en cause réelle
des politiques libérales en place
deuxièmement madame le pen porte une
conception de la france de la république
qui n'a rien à voir avec celle que nous
portons avec le front de gauche
nous nous sommes pour une république de
l'égalité de la fraternité des libertés
pas une république qui divise pas une
république qui se dit mme stigmatise une
partie de des hommes et des femmes qui
vivent sur notre territoire nous sommes
pour la coopération de par le monde ne
sommes pas pour une france fermée
refermée sur elle même
on parle de la colère parce que françois
hollande dit qu'il entend le cri de la
colère qui est porté par jean luc
mélenchon mais il lui oppose les
solutions crédibles qui qui qui joue
l'alternance qu'il incarne seul dit-il
qu'est-ce que vous d'abord en l'air
j'écrivais ce qu'est ce que vous pensez
de ce jeu qu'est répartition des rôles
j'ai été très choquée que françois
hollande puisse dire lors de son meeting
à marseille je suis la gauche je suis
l'alternance il n'est pas en lui-même la
gauche l'alternance
la gauche est diverse le front de gauche
aujourd'hui on voit bien à travers les
sondages représentent une nouvelle donne
à gauche représente une alternative à
gauche et je rappelle que jean luc
mélenchon il ya plusieurs mois déjà fait
une offre publique au parti socialiste
d'un débat sur les propositions pourquoi
je dis que les propositions de françois
hollande ne sont pas crédibles parce que
j'ai bien lu son programme j'ai bien lu
ce son engagement il ya une série de
propositions mais il n'y a pas de levier
économique et démocratique
comment voulez-vous faire vraiment une
politique de gauche si par exemple on ne
se donne pas les moyens de relancer le
crédit
or pour cela pour relancer le crédit il
faut absolument nationaliser sa nombre
de banques créer un pôle financier
public du crédit
il faut se battre au niveau de l'union
européenne pour changer le rôle de la
bca vous savez que la bce c'était dans
les journaux ce matin encore après
minuit mille milliards d'euros aux
banques à 1%
les mêmes banques privées qui ensuite
refusent des crédits aux pme pmi refuse
les crédits aux collectivités
territoriales mais par contre prêtent
aux états à des taux usuraires
bon il faut changer le rôle de la bce à
de très sévères soient sans entrer dans
les détails
idées week-end le programme de françois
ne naît pas chrétien on a beaucoup
disent la même chose du programme union
mélenchon je vous explique pourquoi
pour ce pour mener à une politique de
gauche il faut se donner des leviers
julienne vous en donner un
une politique du crédit deuxièmement
deuxième levier il faut mener le combat
au niveau de l'europe
je rappelle que les députés et les
sénateurs socialistes se sont abstenus
lors du passage du mécanisme européen de
stabilité ce qui est quand même
dommageable
on aurait pu bloquer troisièmement il
faut je dirais des outils démocratiques
la 6ème république je suis étonné tout
le candidat françois hollande est
abandonné cette idée d'une vième
république parce qu'on a besoin du
citoyennes et des citoyens jouent leur
rôle pour la création d'un rapport de
force nous permettant de faire les
réformes nécessaires et les salariés
dans les entreprises
je suis donc pas de crédibilité de
françois hollande
est-ce que donc un bon score du front de
gauche le rendrait crédible selon vous
surtout si on dit que ce bon score de
jean luc mélenchon pourrait favoriser la
nomination de martine aubry à matignon
d'abord je suis j'aimerais que françois
hollande entendent ce que disent les
électrices et les électeurs allemands
gauche avec leur édition avec le choix
du produit ne réussit pas par le choix
du premier ministre c'est pas parce
qu'on prendra martine aubry plutôt que
je sais pas
autre bon jean marc ayrault la question
du sapin imaginons ce soit martine aubry
qu'elle va avoir comme outil pour mener
une politique de bush qu'elle va se
donner comme outil sa discussion pour
rien à voir quel levier économique
démocratique va se donner ouais c'est ça
le vrai débat qu'il faut qu'on est bon
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas avoir ce
débat bustier un reflux du parti
socialiste débattre avec nous sur les
questions programmatiques mans demain
peut-être mais pas de négociations tous
les cas d'entre deux tours sa série club
il n'y a pas il va pas négocier sur un
coin de table c'est une évidence que la
gauche doit se rassembler pour le second
tour mais c'est une évidence on a rien à
négocier on se rassemble et et la
victoire de françois hollande mais je
sois que la victoire de la gauche en
fait on va pas les hova pas né ici c'est
lui qui est entré au second tour
on ne va pas laisser les pieds de la
république cinq ans de plus à nicolas
sarkozy
je suis député j'ai vu le nombre de lois
qui l'a fait passer de casse des acquis
sociaux de remise en cause un certain
nombre de libertés
et puis je pense aussi à l'image de la
france de par le monde je ne pense pas
que nous sortions grandis de ces cinq
années
donc il faut le battre au premier tour
il faut mettre le plus bas possible
extrême droite et il faut battre nicolas
sarkozy au second tour par rassemblement
de la gauche et va clore il va falloir
d'accord donc à mes françois hollande on
l'entend encore dans les mythiques vous
en avez cité un récemment il dit que
les gauches s'annihilent en quelque
sorte un et qu'il ya des votes sans
lendemain c'est celui de mélenchon mais
non justement
le vote pour le front de gauche je viens
de dire ça joue la gagne à gauche
deuxièmement ça tape ça permettra la
réussite de la gauche parce que plus
nous irons nous porterons loin à nos
propositions que j'ai rappelé tout à
l'heure les leviers pour faire une
politique de gauche plus à influençant
leur à l'ensemble de la gauche et plus
la gauche aurait des chances de réussir
parce que moi mon souci c'est pour ça
que j'ai initié le front de gauche c'est
que la gauche gagne mais qu'elle
réussisse deux fois on a été au pouvoir
deux fois nous avons déçu et les
électeurs est bien triste me l'ont dit
de façon nette et sévère il ne faut pas
recommencer une troisième fois
donc cette fois-ci faut se donner les
outils pour réussir donc pas de
négociations mais qui seront peut-être
un rapport de force s'est ouverte lors
des législatives rapprochant le plus
haut de possibles pour les jean luc
mélenchon et ensuite nous aurons des
candidats et des candidates du front de
gauche dans toutes les circonscriptions
voilà parce que nous venons porter les
propositions du front de gauche ont
pendant les élections législatives et
donc nous allons nous continuerons le
débat ne gagneront encore dit l'enjeu
des législatives dans un instant en fait
vous parlez d'un rapport de force mais
on peut entendre bâtons dans les roues
un du char hollandais s'il est élu mais
moi j'ai une démarche constructive
vraiment constructive il faut que le
front de gauche donne à voir aujourd'hui
la gauche a déjà en main les outils
nécessaires pour changer vraiment la vie
voilà je ne veux pas que la gauche
ychoux voilà ça sera notre démarche le
front de gauche dans les semaines et les
mois qui viennent ce sera toujours notre
prévention hollande même objectif que
vous à ne pas échouer
oui il faut qu'ils se donnent les outils
pour cela sur martine aubry ne vous êtes
pas c'est un peu vite et même sèchement
il ya un instant vous étiez copine avec
elle mais c'est pas une question de
rapports d'amis que nous travaillons
ensemble bon elle a été secrétaire du ce
cadre du parti socialiste j'ai eu
l'occasion de la voir à plusieurs
reprises donc c'est une femme qui est
directe et franche
bon mais la question c'est quelle
politique elle devra mettre en oeuvre si
elle était premier millénaire c'est
vraiment de la politique j'en suis bien
sûr mais veut mais beau regretter
qu'elle ne sait pas qu'elle ne se soit
pas plus rapproché des communistes
pendant pendant les primaires
socialistes où nous étions en attente de
signe de sa part non moi j'étais pas en
attente de 6 mai comme
où elle nous a fait passer un message en
disant mais pourquoi les communistes ne
vont pas voter pour moi aux primaires
encore faut-il que j'ai envie de dire l
ai eu dans son discours des primaires un
message adressé à s'était alors l'un des
enjeux du second tour c'est pas
simplement jean luc mélenchon et sa
force de frappe en quelque sorte son
pouvoir sur les convictions de
conviction entendu du rassemblement pour
le second tour c'est aussi le vote
centriste est très important c'est passé
nous vous en soucier des gens je suis la
campagne je vois que son discours pour
l'instant ne lui permet pas de grimper
dans les sondages mais je pense que à la
fois et c'est un homme qui s'inscrit
dans les politiques de la droite
traditionnelle donc qui n'apportent pas
d'alternative à la politique menée
aujourd'hui par nicolas sarkozy et sa
bande
et puis deuxièmement c'est un homme qui
on ne sait pas très bien ce qu'il veut
faire
après le style me faire son second tour
donc les gens ont vite voter pour des
gens qui ont des convictions il est dit
qu'une collation polarisation ça c'est
son problème mais le problème de
françois hollande aujourd'hui on a
peut-être noté parce qu'il ya des appels
du pied aux sites de son côté mais ici
on discute on est à rappeler à faire des
appels du pied à beyrouth je tends même
très inquiétant pour la politique qu'il
va mettre en oeuvre dans les années à
venir c'est très inquiétant
vous savez on vous avait parlé tout à
l'heure de la colère il ya beaucoup de
colère mais il ya aussi beaucoup
d'inspiration beaucoup d'exigences les
hommes et les femmes ont beaucoup
souffert ces dernières années ils
veulent faut à moins que les choses
bougent quand ils sont change et ce
n'est pas par une alliance entre
françois hollande et monsieur berrou que
madame changement franchement non non
mais l'inquiétude est légitime dans le
camp hollandais on se dit voilà jean luc
mélenchon va faire fuir les électeurs
centristes dont nous avons aussi besoin
pour être élu mais la gauche et gagnera
en étant de bouche
elle gagnera en donnant de la dynamite
obtenant de l'envi c'est ce que nous
faisons vite le front de gauche 6 et
pour ça je dis que nous avons contribué
à la victoire aux gens alors avec sa
mère tu occident mais maintenant on va
voir justement quel point le
rapprochement sont envisageables passe
sur le smic
en tout cas on en parlera françois
hollande se contente d'évoquer un coup
de pouce y en a pas eu depuis trois ans
mais on est bien loin des 1700 euros se
trouvent des professions des salaires
était absente de la campagne une semi
seuls à porter cette question des
salaires parce qu'il ya le souhaitable
tout le monde évidemment souhaité un
smic à 1700 sortira pas de la crise sans
les salaires prenant part l'on
s'interroge donc sur la suite l'après
présidentielle et législatives le
gouvernement de françois hollande
pour l'instant vous avez rappelé que
vous êtes député le ps se contente de ne
pas présenter de candidat face au
communiste se fondant c'est faux faux
donc tu t'es cette inscription il ya des
députés communistes sortants et les
candidats le parti socialiste et des
candidats
sinon au niveau des accords pour les
législatives
peut-être que vous réclamez la le même
traitement même plus favorable que les
écologistes ont dit non on en parle dans
un instant et sur les rapports à gauche
toujours rugueux
on le constate l'enquète de florence
maurice jean luc mélenchon l'a dit et
répété pas question de participer à un
gouvernement en cas d'élection de
françois hollande positionnement sincère
ou bien coup de bluff pour faire monter
les enchères
difficile à savoir pour le moment si
d'ores et déjà il ya un ralliement qui
doit être annoncé cela peut
potentiellement déstabiliser une partie
des électeurs se disent en fait on ne
vote pas pour faire pression sur contre
hollande mais au contraire pour faire en
sorte d'accompagner la présence de
certains dirigeants soient communistes
sur les fronts de gauche au sein du
prochain gouvernement
car en fait au front de gauche on pense
déjà au coude après les législatives
objectif surfer sur la vague de cette
présidentielle et obtenir un groupe
puissant à l'assemblée pour infléchir le
programme de françois hollande jugé trop
rigoureux bref créer une vraie
opposition à gauche c'est donc une
partie à 4 tours qui se joue de quoi
agacer les anciens camarades
nostalgiques de l'expérience du
gouvernement jospin
leur démarche est une démarche tactique
par rapport à eux-mêmes
moi je mon engagement unitaire il est
pour la gauche il est pour que la gauche
gagne dans son ensemble dans sa
diversité par uche appelle une gauche
contre l'hôte une gauche qui tiendrait
la radicalité ça ne veut rien dire la
radicalité au pcf qu'on dit souvent pro
gouvernement ont ce rallye pour le
moment à la position de jean luc
mélenchon
pas question de renier celui qui a
ressuscité le parti communiste
mais pierre laurent le secrétaire
national se ménage une porte de sortie
participer ou non un gouvernement tout
dépendra des accords passés pour les
législatives et du rapport de force qui
en suivra
quoi qu'il en soit au parti socialiste
on multiplie les appels à l'unité je
dise à marie-george qu'elle sait très
bien puisque nous sommes tous les deux
élus en seine saint denis que la gauche
est diverse et que le plus important
c'est toujours la capacité qu elle à se
rassembler à avoir des paroles qui
peuvent être différentes dans un premier
temps et ensuite à afficher une force
voila voila afficher une force appel à
l'unité marie george buffet qu'est ce
que vous répondez était encore à
françois hollande
et qui dit à propos des voitures sont en
premier tour pourquoi faire compliqué
quand on peut faire simple
et vous savez qu'on joue gros pour les
français et les françaises ils viennent
de vivre aux cinq ans de pouvoir de
nicolas sarkozy
si la gauche gagne il faut vraiment
qu'elle soit en capacité de résoudre les
problèmes que connaissent nos
compatriotes et ces problèmes sont
graves et donc nous le front de gauche
nous sommes des hommes et des femmes
responsables
nous voulons mettre en oeuvre un
programme qui permet de répondre aux
attentes donc je trouve quand même assez
incroyable que au simplement au nom de
l'unité on dise taisez vous ou vos
propositions n'en a rien à faire ça pour
faire sa défense pour faire ça mais ça
veut rien dire les français n'attendent
pas ils sont pas idiots les français
n'attendent pas qu'on leur fasse 5 comme
si on parlait à des enfants ils
attendent qu'on leur fasse des
propositions aux capacités de répondre à
leurs exigences et autres choses
s'améliorent comme c est avec nous pour
aller plus au fond des choses
justement un sur les éléments
programmatiques notamment mont saint
michel mont cervin buffet verrait un peu
agacé pendant le reportage alors que je
ne comprends pas qu'on puisse encore
dire aujourd'hui que nous allons
négocier pour les législatives
des places pour les députés du front de
gauche nous aurons des candidates et des
candidats dans toutes les
circonscriptions
sauf s'il y avait danger fn à ce moment
là bien évidemment il faudra un candidat
unique de la gauche mais partout ils
auront des sinon nous aurons des
candidats les gones est pourquoi parce
que vous rendez compte nous menons
campagne à la présidentielle sur un
programme nous construisions ce
programme notamment avec les salariés et
les syndicalistes les hommes et des
femmes qui sont dans nos assemblées
citoyennes et puis
la présidentielle lors du vaste
programme on en a plus rien à faire
et puis on va aller chercher les
circonscriptions m en passant un accord
avec le parti socialiste en faisant un
compromis sur un programme qui ne
marchera pas c'est pas du tout elle le
front de gauche il va vivre dans les
années qui viennent il va se poursuivre
dont nous aurons des candidates et des
candidats à parité dans toutes les
circonscriptions du front de gauche il
espère apprendre les pronoms les chances
de prenons les choses dans l'ordre
je vous ai vu agacé quand le reportage
évoqué la possibilité que les
communistes ou des membres du front de
gauche entre gouvernements mais on ne va
pas au gouvernement pour chercher des
sièges monsieur c'est comme pour
législatives
on va au gouvernement pour gérer le pays
et donc pour mettre en oeuvre une
politique et l'on croit nous vous prions
groupe iii qu'elle soit efficace si nous
allons demain gouvernement sur l'humain
d'abord le programme du front de gauche
nous aurons des ministres du front de
gauche s'étaient visant le film et si
c'est un gouvernement qui est sur la
politique proposée à l'heure actuelle
par françois hollande nous n'irons pas
au gouvernement dit le pont d'ici le 17
juin le second tour des élections
législatives
pensez vous que vous avez les moyens
d'infléchir la position de françois fait
des mois que jean luc mélenchon fait une
offre très unitaire de débat public pas
de petite négociation cachette de débat
public sur les propositions des uns et
des autres pour l'instant on nous répond
non eh bien j'espère que plus on va être
le grand saut jean luc mélenchon
peut-être que ça ouvrira les oreilles
quand même parce que vous avez envie
d'être entendu mais surtout ici pas un
point n'hésite pas n'essaie pas de
maison 3 mais emblématique pour résumer
mais je vous les ai dit précédemment la
6ème république
une de nouvelles avancées pour que les
citoyennes et les citoyennes prennent
part aux décisions et que les salariés
l'organisation syndicale dans les
entreprises puissent se mêler de la
gestion de leur entreprise auprès pondre
des maths exempt deuxièmement la
question de reprendre en main les
marchés et le crédit on a besoin d'une
relance industrielle n'a besoin d'une
relance de l'investissement il faut du
crédit en jeu les banques privées de
français langue il faut nationaliser des
banques lui faire un pôle financier
public et il faut surtout changer le
rôle de la bce
on ne peut pas continuer à faire la bce
prête ou privés et ne prêtent pas aux
états ne prête pas ne concourent pas à
l'investissement industriel
troisièmement je pense qu'il faut
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés et des familles et c'est
d'abord ce pour deux raisons
parce qu'il en a besoin on ne vit plus
aujourd'hui avec le smig à 1300 et
quelque chose euros ça veut dire un peu
plus de 1000 euros qui rendent
réellement dans les colonnes dans le
budget familial
on ne peut pas vivre comme ça on ne peut
pas payer son loyer le gaz électricité
qui augmente et on nous avait dit qu'on
allait privatiser baisser le prix de
l'électricité on a vu le résultat
on ne peut pas les gens ne mangent plus
en fin de mois donc il faut augmenter le
sli deuxièmement c'est bon de le monter
les salaires parce que ça permet une
relance une relance de la consommation
et ça va bien de faire redémarrer
l'économie dont il une mesure efficace
et je suis étonné que peu jean luc
mélenchon sur le seul candidat qui pose
cette question clairement cette question
des salaires
quel est le rapport de force nécessaire
pour le front de gauche à la
présidentielle et aux élections
législatives pour causer sur le dance
dans le sens dans ce sens la surchauffe
de 90% par jour avec mes chansons je
n'en sais rien ce qui va se passer il
reste cinq jours voilà il faut surtout
pas que nos amis du front de gauche
relâche l'effort et parce que souvent
les fatigues en relâche les forces et le
moment où plein de gens se décident de
nous il faut y aller je me mets pas de
plafond sur le score de jean lui à la
présidentielle j'espère qu'il va être
très très haut
bon et puis aux législatives il faut
aller chercher un très fort où il peut
être au second tour l'élection
présidentielle on se mettrait des freins
pourquoi on irait aux jambes écouter ou
en fin de compte ce n'est pas la peine
de voter pour lui parce qu'on n'a aucun
espoir et cousines ont elles aussi
votons pour avec mélenchon c'est un vote
utile
n'ayez pas peur allez-y s'il n'y a pas
de ministre front de gauche dans
gouvernement en cas de victoire de
françois hollande ce sera donc le
soutien sans la participation mais on
peut être très actif on faisait au
soutient s'être pas si que je soutiens
on peut être très actif avec un fort
groupe front de gauche à l'assemblée
nationale avec nos amis front de gauche
du sénat
on peut à tout moment leur moment du
budget au moment des lois on peut
améliorer tout ce qui ce fait on peut
apporter des propositions vont se battre
pour ses propositions rentrer dans la
loi et puis aussi
moi je pense qu'il faut être je vais
peut-être vous étonner
la campagne ne s'arrêtera pas le 17 juin
moi je pense qu'il faut être pendant
cinq ans en campagne c'est à dire cinq
ans avec les hommes et les femmes pour
faire des assemblées citoyennes pour
mobiliser pour créer des rapports de
force sur nos propositions
voilà on va continuer à se battre avec
les ceux et celles qui ont voté front de
gauche ou qui vont nous rejoindra pas le
front de gauche sous un éventuel
quinquennat françois hollande c'est donc
un pied dans les institutions un pied
dans le mouvement social si je suis bien
sûr nous avons besoin d'une loi sociale
vous savez j'étais hier avec plusieurs
dizaines de syndicalistes qui ont lancé
l'appel des syndicats lice pour le vote
jean luc mélenchon pourquoi nous avons
un tel rayonnement chez syndicalisme
c'est parce que nous avons pris en
compte les solutions alternatives dans
chaque entreprise en lutte et nous avons
construit les réponses programmatique
c'est à dire nous avons créé la
convergence entre les luttes sociales et
la réponse politique
il faudra continuer à prier que moi
aujourd'hui si les socialistes nous
écoutent ils vont se dire ouh la la
prions le ciel pour qu'on ait la
majorité à nous tout seul c'est vraiment
s'ils ont ça en tête
c'est décourageant parce que si vous
écoutez pourquoi pour bouder la majorité
celui pour mener une commune politique
pépère qui ne changera rien et qui
laissera l'europe continue à nous
diriger à nous imposer des politiques
d'austérité mais non fautive
moi j'appelle les électeurs électrices
socialiste après se résoudre à ça ça
rien d'enthousiasmant franchement ce que
vous me dire me dire s'ils veulent
vraiment que ça bouge toute la gauche et
du courage et de l'audace qu'il rejoigne
le groupe front de gauche en dénonçant
en même temps comme il ya rien y'a rien
à récupérer dans le programme de
françois langot noter qu'il n'est pas
crédible en europe
annoncé jeudi que ce n'est pas crédible
parce qu'ils ne se donnent pas les
leviers nécessaires pour mettre en
oeuvre ce programme il ya des poufs
propositions qu'on retrouve dans le
programme de françois hollande pour
retrouve dans probable selon lui bien au
chaud sauf que pour les mettre en oeuvre
il faut dégager les moyens financiers il
faut dégager les rapports de forces
démocratiques qui nous on n'y arrivera
pas une chose mais ton il y aura un
collectif budgétaire au mois de juillet
si françois hollande remporté l'élection
présidentielle françois hollande a déjà
dit qu'il voulait un retour du déficit
de la france à 3% du pib avec certains
cortèges de d'effort est ce que vous
voteriez un budget qui va dans ce sens
si on va ré qui ont réduit à 3% en
baissant les dépenses publiques c'est
non c'est non
parce qu'aujourd'hui déjà on a saccagé
il dépense publique dont les dépenses
publiques et sont utiles utile c'est un
investissement du ballon pour avoir un
groupe front de gauche à l'assemblée qui
retoque qui votent non en premier
sa démarche ne sera pas celle ci d'abord
nous allons faire des propositions
alternatives sur le collectif budgétaire
nous allons proposer la réforme de la
fiscalité léonce tranches de revenus que
nous avons disputées tout au long de
cette campagne nous allons proposer un
nouvel impôt sur les sociétés nous
allons faire des propositions très
concrètes très réaliste et michel sapin
ou jérôme cahuzac ministre du budget
retoque ces propositions quelle sera
votre position vous voterez non au
budget transmis comme vous avez voté non
au budget disposition j'espère que ce
sera pas le cas j'espère que quand même
et on dégagera une majorité dans cette
assemblée qui aura l'intelligence de
dire que l'heure n'est plus à la
poursuite de la réduction des dépenses
publiques
c'est ce qui a été fait pendant cinq ans
donc est-ce qu'on veut changer ou est ce
qu'on ne peut pas changer mais que leur
rentrée de la sec mais que c'était en
fait justement très tôt celui de fonds
ont fixé un objectif traitant ce sujet
déficit zéro par une non non et non un
état emprunte c'est tout à fait justifié
comme tous les petits vite éteint
territoriale emprunte pour investir
c'est bon pour l'économie
ses bourreaux et police les gens quand
on est perclus de dettes mais la dette
elle est composée de quoi aller composé
d'une des tutti
si chère à l'emprunt pour
l'investissement et paie une dette n'est
pas utile c'est les charges financières
le remboursement des banques privées
pour résoudre celle ci moi je propose la
bce prenne directement aux états 1%
voilà donc la question de la dette je
les régler la crise de la dette ça ne
veut rien dire en soi si la crise du
système bancaire qu'ils allaient cause
de ses difficultés famille vous
soutiendrez la démarche de françois
hollande encore une fois s'il est élu
président de la république de renégocier
le traité européen je pense que là il y
aura des communiqués front de gauche
saluant l'action du nouveau président de
la république dans ce sens là il faut
complètement modifier le traité pourquoi
sony ne sont pas renégocier la marche
vous rendez compte que nous vivons
aujourd'hui sur le traité de lisbonne
qui est un traité qui prône la libre
concurrence donc à casse de nos services
publics de nos entreprises publiques
c'est un traité qui mais je dirais en
hand pin's de tout ce que vous avez
refusé en 2005 il a refusé de me donne
et on est qu'une majorité des lectrices
deter socialistes ont refusé en 2005
il faut aussi que françois hollande se
souviennent de cela le parti socialiste
a appelé à voter oui au traité
constitutionnel libérale et une majorité
d'hommes et de femmes se référant parti
socialiste ont voté non parce qu'ils
voulaient construire une autre europe là
nous nous respecterons son vote
souhaitez vous que jean luc mélenchon
soit candidat à l'élection aux élections
législatives mais ça sera son choix
jean luc mélenchon c'est un choix
individuel excusez moi c'est moi
j'espère surtout que le front de gauche
va se poursuivre et que dans le cadre de
ce front de gauche jean-luc mélenchon
continuera à jouer un rôle très
important justement qu'allez vous faire
vous les communistes du du soldat pardon
du maréchal mélenchon après l'élection
présidentielle parce que là tout de même
il a pris certaine envergure tout
automatique
nous l'avons choisi comme candidat il
fait une campagne formidable il monte
dans les sondages il a pris une grande
envergure politique je voudrais pouvoir
je peux que me féliciter et vous savez
démocratie ça existe une composante dans
quel parti communiste parti de gauche
est donc c'est jean luc mélenchon de
chef
on a trois parties beaux partis qui sont
venus se joindre à eux
on ne veut pas créer un nouveau parti où
vous restez un second parce qu'on y
trouve ça reste ouvert
d'où tu peux venir de ranger un chef
mais il y aura des animateurs du front
maréchal et jean-luc sera certainement
oui un porte-parole essentiel du front
quand je vais vous rendez compte que on
ne sort pas d'une présidentielle sans
porter rayonner et donc il faut qu'il
continue à rayonner pendant que sa place
est à l'assemblée ça ne compte pas moins
de 10 si vous êtes drôlement envie vous
auriez pas de moi si le mot ça sera très
bien oui d'accord et des adhésions des
adhésions directes au front de gauche ça
serait possible instant nous on continue
la forme parce qu'il ya des hommes et
des femmes
bon en ce moment là beaucoup d'adhésions
moi je vois on a encore fait et 35
nouveaux adhérents comme ici beaucoup
beaucoup de nouveaux d'adhésion au parti
communiste parce que les gens
reconnaissent la démarche que nous avons
eues avec le front de gauche et j'ai
envie de dire où en vie d'être de cette
aventure il ya des adhésions aussi au
parti de gauche bon petit un courant
d'adhésion vers nous je trouve ça
formidable
des hommes et des femmes qui n'ont pas
envie d'adhérer à un parti à une
composante du front de gauche
il faut qu'on trouve le moyen de les
associer c'est ce qu'on est en train de
travailler l'été a semblé citoyens
financièrement financièrement ce serait
pas plus simple des adhésions directes
au flanc gauche fait un seul parti
n'entend pas financé c'est une question
de la partie ça rien à voir elle était
fiancée est ce qu'on veut arrêter de
loger alors non est ce qu on veut un
seul parti c'est à dire on ferme où
est-ce qu'on veut garder chacun selon sa
culture sont identiques son identité et
on laisse ouvert le front de gauche à
des hommes et des femmes ou à d'autres
organisations qui veulent le rejoindre
et ouvert deux petites questions travail
très rapide
êtes vous gêné par le fait que jean luc
mélenchon est assisté à la remise de la
légion d'honneur à patrick buisson le
conseiller niveau très droitier de
nicolas sarkozy expliqué
une histoire il ya des choses plus
importantes à discuter en soufflant
voulait pas donc être à 2020 les
jeûneurs de l'homme qui est responsable
dit on de la droitisation de la campagne
de nicolas fille de remise je m'énerve
vraiment ce que vous oubliez car cet
ancien et une dernière chose si j'avais
posé la question dans ces termes à jean
luc mélenchon est il mort est demeuré
aspergé ogm kercher sans doute plus
sérieusement le programme du front de
gauche prévoit prévoit de la libé de
libérer les médias est votre candidat
n'arrête pas de bousculer voire
d'insultés parfois les journalistes ça
vous gêne son comportement envers la
presse est un homme de passion il est
comme ça bon bon une journaliste parfois
les rendre aussi donc
écoutez moi je chacun son rôle chacun sa
façon d'être caractère bon c'est
tellement secondaire par rapport à ce
que les gens attendent de nous est ce
que les gens veulent qu'on débat qui
veulent qu'on parle emploi pouvoir
d'achat il veut qu'on parle des services
publics de tout ça de l'épaule ses deux
fils de se rendre
merci samian council montarnaud va
arriver je vous ai vu aussi hérité moi
tout à l'heure notamment quand on a vu
robert hue vous n'avez pas les mêmes
souvenirs que lui manifestement de
françois hollande lui sont des îles
c'est bien l'ensemble de l'église
homologues de partie c'est un choix être
compétente et visuelle ouais bah oui
d'accord mais bon c'est important il a
dirigé le parti umma ici son choix
depuis ouais ouais d'accord mais il n'a
pas les mêmes souvenirs que vous de
françois hollande manifestement huit
mois où sont les questions de bonheur
vraiment si pengassan question bonhomme
c'est une question des bouchons qui
bouge françois hollande il annonce par
exemple une possible tva plus élevées
sur les produits de luxe il a nancy
mille prof de plus dès la rentrée de
septembre
ça c'est bon ça le front de gauche monte
plus ça fait bouger c'est bien il va
nous regarder va dans le bon sens ah ben
quand il fait gris fait des propositions
qui reprennent ou pas cette publicité
sur les produits il faut surtout faire
une grande réforme de la fiscalité pour
le plus injuste qui soit perrine arrive
justement
marie george buffet ce petit rappel de
votre participation gouvernementale
comme
ministre de la jeunesse et des sports
sous lionel jospin
même à droite on salue encore
aujourd'hui votre action tam traduit si
marie george buffet peut se vanter
d'avoir atteint le score le plus bas
jamais obtenu par les communistes à la
présidentielle il y à un domaine où elle
a recueilli tous les suffrages
y compris ceux de la droite le sport ah
oui je pense que c'était une bonne
ministre qu'elle a vraiment dans le
domaine de la
mélioration justement moral entre
guillemets l'histoire des conditions la
lutte contre le dopage est là elle a
effectivement fait mort et c'est des
dossiers mais aujourd'hui en réalité il
n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas d'énorme
différence entre ce qui constituerait
une politique de gauche une politique de
droit dans le domaine du sport enfin par
de l'agitation dans les mots et il n'y a
pas de réalité dans le fond alors le
sport un sujet de consensus
pas pour la députée communiste qui veut
en faire un enjeu scrutin et qui dénonce
les dix ans de gestion de la droite
disant de cassan bon c'est un grand
classique de dire que ses prédécesseurs
n'ont rien fait et que ses successeurs
sont des imbéciles mais je pense que ça
va pas du tout dans le sens de l'intérêt
général
ah oui mais les petites phrases
assassines c'est tout ce qui reste pour
que l'on parle du sport en termes
politiques les médias se régalent est
aussi des images des politiques qui
mouillent le maillot
obama et le basket nicolas sarkozy et le
jogging mais tout cela reste bien
anecdotique
résultat le sport c'est l'un des grands
oubliés de la campagne présidentielle
sauf quand on aborde le sujet épineux
des salaires des footballeurs
abbas a de temps parler à leur père et
avec buffet oui vous êtes indignés en
regardons encore ce sujet vous n'êtes
pas d'accord qu'il faut justement il
faut arrêter de penser que le sport
c'est la grande muette qui a pas d'enjeu
politique dans le sport lorsque pendant
cinq ans nous n'avons eu les candidats à
la présidentielle par nous avons obtenu
un très grand forum sur le sport je peux
vous dire notre programme sur le sport
est très conscient par les justes mais
lorsque pendant cinq ans nous n'avons eu
aucune loi je dirais cadre sur le sport
lorsque nous avons eu toute une série de
petites lois qui ont cassé tout ce qui
faisait la protection du sport par
rapport à l'argent on a permis la
dernière loi qui est passé c'est une loi
qui ouvre la possibilité d'un multi
propriété des clubs professionnels par
les mêmes actionnaires
c'est des lois qui permettent de
transformer un club sportif
professionnel à une société anonyme de
droit commun ce sont des lois qui ont
autorisé les paris en ligne
le budget des sports aujourd'hui les
paris de l'argent venu des paris en
ligne est majoritaire par rapport à
l'argent public nous sommes dépendants
de la diction jeu aujourd'hui pour le
budget du 5 au 12 janvier une politique
de droite pour le sport est une
politique différente de gauche
pour le sport français d'accord avec la
députée socialiste valérie fourneyron
qui travaille justement sur ces
questions de sport pour françois
hollande
elle dit que nicolas sarkozy laisse le
monde sportif comme un champ de ruines
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai j'ai eu
souvent l'occasion de discuter avec
valérie fourneyron qu'est ce que nous
sommes dans la même commission est que
nous sommes passionnés des questions du
sport toutes les deux oui je pense que
c'est l'expression juste mais
aujourd'hui il ya 100 sportifs qui
s'engagent pour françois hollande donc
faut croire que c'est le candidat qui
leur plaît le plus
mais pour ces 100 sportifs ça faisait un
lieu sans sportif ne reflète pas
l'ensemble des salles historiques that
if beaucoup de dans le jeu tout croyant
sportif français d'anciens jeux des yeux
l'un bientôt les regardant les
programmes bon en parler
oui par exemple est-ce qu'on reconstruit
un grand ministère des sports avec à la
fois un budget mais également avec une
administration savez qu'aujourd'hui les
directions départementales et les
direction régionale jeunesse et sport
ont été fondues dans les grandes
directions de la cohésion sociale
alors que ces fonctionnaires étaient des
fonctionnaires je les appelais souvent
les fonctionnaires militants qu'ils
étaient en lien direct avec le monde
sportif avec les associations
d'éducation populaire et de jeunesse on
a détruit tout cela est ce qu'on
reconstruit ce grand ministère mais un
grand ministère avec quel budget jean
luc mélenchon propose d'aller jusqu'à 1
% du budget national oui pour le médecin
dispose que ça c'est réaliste on à 0,15
pour s'envoler
c'est vraiment ça représente très bien
où on trouve l'argent mais où je voulais
dit tout à l'heure il faut faire une
grande réforme de la fiscalité pour
faire rentrer l'argent dans les caisses
de l'état
parce que si on est soudés dans l'île de
dix courses tout sujet qu'on ne peut
rien faire parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'argent font en effet mais table finale
donc il faut taxer tout azimut par
exemple jean luc mélenchon il aimerait
accélérer ses montagnes comme d'un patin
madrid c'est possible ça il ne faut pas
taxer tout a dit mais bon il faut faire
d'abord un impôt progressif qui soit
vraiment un impôt progressif c'est à
dire que selon sa fortune on participe
aux dépenses publiques et c'est pour ça
que nous proposons de porter à onze
strange l'impôt sur le revenu ensuite il
faut en effet faire cotiser les revenus
financiers faire participer les revenus
financiers à la dépense publique enfin
il faut en effet à augmenter la taxation
les impôts ce les grands groupes qui ne
pensent que la spéculation est par
contre soulager les pme pmi qui sont
écrasés par la charge financière
mais alors pour revenir au monde sportif
est ce qu'il faut taxer les
équipementiers sportifs comme nine
c'est parti pour monde ce serait juste
mais justement justement taupe on savait
que le l'image ça rapporte une image
assez grand écran au groupe hélie normal
qui donne à peu au sport aussi quand
même si j'aime beaucoup de gens ils
payent très cher les sportifs pour avoir
le droit de participer non pas
simplement un financement de quelques
sportifs professionnels mais au
financement du développement du sport
pour tous et tous dans notre pays est-ce
qu'il faut aussi appliquer au monde
sportif
la règle de jean luc mélenchon c'est à
dire un salaire plafond il faut pas dans
une même entreprise pas d'écart
supérieur entre un avant pourra par
exemple lorsqu'on applique cette règle
au psg
le salarié de base si on estime qu'ils
gagnent 2000 euros par mois ce qui est
déjà beaucoup ça veut dire que le joueur
le plus payé du psg ne pourra pas gagner
plus de 40000 euros par mois qui était
normal loin mais on est déjà loin de
salaire mensuel des joueurs du psg
est ce que ce n'est pas utopique mais
c'est pas le petit tibet ce que ça veut
dire et ce n'est pas utopique c'est un
besoin je ne suis pas le seul à le dire
michel platini lorsqu'il a pris la tête
du football européen
la première chose qu'il a travaillé si
surfer plus fair play financier parce
qu'on ne peut pas continuer cette course
à l'argent des clubs professionnels de
foot
voyage qui justement la réponse de
michel platini c'est qu'il faut une
réponse européenne par rapport à cela ça
serait en train de travailler et j'ai
envie de dire il faut l'accompagnement
politique lorsque nous avons entamé la
lutte contre le dopage
nous avons démarré par l'action
politique au niveau de l'union
européenne j'ai convaincu 1 1
les 15 ministres des sports de l'époque
et ensuite nous avons convaincu le
mouvement sportif de créer une agence
mondiale antidopage
la vie celle platini a commencé avec le
fair play financier
si les les pays européens et politiques
entendu pour l'instant mais justement si
si les les 27 ministres des sports
prenez la décision d'accompagner cette
marche vers le fair play financier pour
faire baisser les budgets des clubs
baisser les salaires et surtout baisser
le montant du transfert
eh bien nous pourrions arriver à avoir
un peu plus d'éthique dans le sport est
très clair vous êtes pour un salaire
maximum pour les sportifs il expliqué
sur les exilés fiscaux jean luc
mélenchon lui ne veut pas que les
sportifs de haut niveau qui sont
domiciliées en suisse ou à monaco par
exemple porte le maillot national à ce
que ça veut dire dans ces cas là on a
plus d' équipes françaises de tmx
mais c'est une incitation à ce qu'ils
reviennent s'installer au niveau fiscal
en france
enfin écoutez on ne peut pas avoir le
beurre et l'argent du beurre
on ne peut pas avoir des salaires
mirobolants et ne pas contribuer je
dirai à la solidarité du pays dont vos
porte les couleurs ça me paraît quand
même tout simplement du bon sens au fait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de l'équipe de
france de tennis
il faut qu'ils reviennent se déclarer
fiscalement en france
mais comment vous les inciter si vous
installez les taxis plus de 100 partis
plafonner leurs salaires excusez moi
monsieur est quand même avoir un peu de
morale en politique
est-ce qu excusez moi est ce qu'on peut
avoir un peu de mordant est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la vision politique ça
doit être plus vous faites de free moi
vous payer d'impôts mieux c'est moi
c'est pas ma vision est ce qu il pose
pas dans la reconnaissance d'un talent
et la reconnaissance des talents mais
quand vous êtes ingénieur quand vous
êtes chercheur vous allez aussi du
talent ils n'ont pas tout à fait les
mêmes faits concernant la taxe de 75 %
sur les revenus supérieurs à un million
d'euros
à propos des sportifs justement mais
également des artistes françois hollande
et souligne la nécessité d' étaler
peut-être les revenus dans le temps
qu'en pensez vous un accommodement que
vous trouveriez acceptable franchement
je pense aussi pas une mesure si la
réforme de la fiscalité c'est lyon
s'accroche à un mur bien ok sur la
dynamique mélenchon va revenir un petit
peu à cette campagne présidentielle
comment vous vous avez vécu
personnellement cette dynamique et qui a
quand même ressusciter un petit peu la
base du parti communiste ont suscité ou
le terme est un peu fort mais avec
bonheur sur le mode je le paie c'était
quand même pas au plus haut se porte
bien son nom on est d'accord sur le
constat est mort et ressuscité qui
d'accord non c'est avec beaucoup de
bonheur
nous menons une campagne je dirais
dynamique
nous avons beaucoup d'amis de femmes qui
nous rejoignent
nous on sent que nous portons un espoir
les militants et les militantes sont
déchaînés cobayes nous faisons les
meeting monstre
voilà donc oui du bonheur et puis moins
espérer venez mai 2005 autour de votre
assurance le dic tous et toutes
c'est à dire que quand on a démarré on
nous regardait en disant en gros 1
et puis petit à petit les sondages
montrent que ça prend mais c'est pas
qu'il sondage moi je veux bien aller
nous a semblé dans les villes c'est
rassemble de plus en plus de 2000 femmes
des gens qu'on ne connaissait pas allé
du bon donc oui on non moi je ne pensais
pas qu'on puisse aussi rapidement parce
que le front de gauche a fait trois ans
que nous l'avons constitué que nous
puissions aussi rapidement représenter
une alternative à gauche ou non qu'ils à
coire en plus jean luc mélenchon que
vous n'aviez pas par exemple jean luc
était très beau présenter avant même
beaucoup à sa personnalité jean luc est
un très bon candidat c'est bon mais
c'est aussi une dynamique qui secret
c'est aussi quelque chose une pression
de charisme non mais chercher demain tu
voulais me tester qu'il a plus de
charisme comme moi je vais vous le dire
comme ça non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que moi quand j'ai ici le front de
gauche il ya quatre ans je ne pensais
pas que mon si rapidement nous allions
créer c'est cet espoir cette dynamique
site internet vous angoisse pas parfois
on y va où là on a lancé un personnage
ne pas dire une créature qui va finir
par nous dévorer ou peut-être parce que
nous n'avons pas la même conception de
la vie politique je vous assure que les
militantes et les militants du front de
gauche qu'ils appartiennent à tel ou tel
parti ou qu'ils appartiennent à aucun
parti ne sont pas prêts à regarder le
sauveur suprême
non ce sont des acteurs et des actrices
de la vie politique et jean luc
mélenchon et parmi ses acteurs ses
actrices
et voilà il joue un rôle particulier
paraît bien que cette question que j'ai
posée qui vous choque encore une elle a
été posée par des par des responsables
communistes valeur il faut que le parti
communiste garde à ses dépens
battre aujourd'hui maintenant ici alors
il va vous vous êtes en perturbant de
france vous avez des mains non mais et
alors adam braz est alors un nom et un
débat interne au parti communiste kke a
été passionnant pour le qui a été
passionnant parce que il a été
passionnant sur la constitution pas du
front de gauche
et puis ensuite il a été passionnant
dans un deuxième moment sur le choix du
candidat
des camarades pensé qu'il fallait un
candidat issu du parti communiste était
le même débat que nous enseignons 2007
avec le résultat que nous avons en tant
qu'il est encore temps
il propose la majorité des communistes a
pensé qu'il fallait en effet que ce soit
jean luc mélenchon parce que ça donnait
à voir de la constitution du front de
gauche juste petite toute petite
dernière question devant la nature
françois hollande que vous avez côtoyé
quand il était à la tête du parti
socialiste comment vous voyez sa
trajectoire pour cette campagne
présidentielle vous qu'est-ce comment
vous jugez vous sa campagne d'un mot pas
en valais je l'écouté attentivement je
redonne les propositions les engagements
les fois son engagement
je touche aux personnes vous l'avez
quand même bienvenu
oui quand vous étiez le nez du pc du ps
dont john o'shea magnifiquement le net
donc je vois pas de changement un accord
alors petite question
jacques chirac a choisi françois
hollande c'est ce que rapporte son
biographe enfin de l'auteur de ces
mémoires sont luc barré et tout le clan
chirac sauf bernadette vote pour les
candidats socialistes votre réaction de
marie george buffet mais je trouve ça
peut être le chemin parce que y'a
bernadette qui fait les chirac qui fait
la campagne de sarkozy
oui j'en ai je dit ça fait un bon ben
voila si j'écoutais si une affaire de
famille qui discute bien autour du rôti
lé dimanche midi voilà merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec le volet car on n'est
pas perdu votre pêche
moi je préfère vous courrez d'un meeting
évidemment vous aussi vous ne levait pas
le pied jusque au premier tour merci
d'avoir été avec nous dans cette édition
de preuve par trois bonsoir a très vite
le président de la république il est
exigeant et il veut la transparence sur
le fonctionnement de l'elysée il a même
réduit le nombre de collaborateurs
mais dans le même temps il met pour lui
même et quand il fait un voyage officiel
dans l'avion de la république française
je vous le dis monsieur duquel ils
payent lui-même son dentifrice les
politiques et l'argent en ces temps de
campagne mais aussi en ces temps de
crise le sujet peut vite devenir
polémique alors les politiques vif qui
comme nous travail t-il pour l'intérêt
général et se soucie t'il vraiment de
nous quelle est leur rapport à l'argent
cette semaine nous déshabillons en tout
bien tout honneur nicolas françois jean
luc et d'égout déshabillons-les
présentée par hélène risser c'est
mercredi à 18h15 sur public sénat du
jour les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
aberration
merci
messieurs
je suis charles pasqua
j'ai été sénateur marmandais s'est
rassemblée à plusieurs reprises
je crois que j ai exercé j'ai exercé des
responsabilités au parlement pendant
plus de vingt ans j'ai été deux fois
ministre de l'intérieur
et puis d'autre part membre du parlement
européen
je suis donc plus de 30 ans d'expérience
de la vie politique dans ce pays
une des premières lois qui a été mise en
discussion et y est la loi sur la
réforme de l'éducation nationale
présentée par alain savary le vote de la
loi savary n'aurait dû poser aucun
problème mais et voilà qu avant que ce
texte ne vienne un examen au parlement
une série d'amendements ont eu comme
conséquence de durcir ce texte
il s'agissait d'un projet attentatoire à
une liberté essentielle le droit pour
les familles de choisir librement comme
elle l'entendait le mode d'éducation de
leurs enfants et nous nous sommes
trouvés tout d'un coup dans une
situation de conflit
william power avec lequel j'avais des
relations très très suivi me demande
d'aller le voir il me dit j'ai demandé à
voir françois mi temps je vais le voir
avec quatre amendements qui devraient
permettre de régler tout ça sans
histoire je lui ai dit je vous retrouve
bien optimiste il est parti pour à
françois mi temps je me rappelle j'étais
sur le boulevard saint germain
lorsque l'on m'a fait chercher à manille
le programme pair
vienne rentrée il veut voir d'urgence il
me dit ça s'est très mal passé il a
refusé toute discussion et il m'a dit
vous avez déjà fait partir un paysan de
la république vous ne pourrez pas partir
en 2d je n'accepterai aucune discussion
alors alain poher me dit jouan pas tous
comment pourront faire moi je vais
réfléchir en tunnel montre autant et je
m'étais dit il y a une seule parade mais
peut-être que ça va vous paraître
excessif et difficile à mettre en oeuvre
une unique au monde
jeudi c'est l'appel au référendum le
président de la république qui était une
femme politique s'est rendu compte qu'il
était engagé dans une affaire qui ne
pouvait que mal tourné et donc il a
décidé de retirer le texte est ensuite
dans une deuxième époque dans une
deuxième étape il a décidé tout
simplement de l'annuler alors pierre
mauroy s'est sentie complètement
désavoué et il en a tiré les leçons
il a démissionné de son poste de premier
ministre
ce qui m'a permis de dire que à cette
occasion le sénat avait renversé le
where 2 mars qu'il était pas à la
pratique constitutionnelle normale
oui oui oui oui oui oui il ya longtemps
que monsieur fabius a atteint son niveau
d'incompétence qu'il démissionne c'est
le seul service qu'ils puissent encore
rendre à la république
oh mais c'étaient des termes très forts
il y avait une tension palpable
vous savez j'étais allé à nouvelle
calédonie moi même j'y étais allé
d'abord pour faire un contrôle sur place
de la télévision
et puis avait une très grande réunion
publique où il prête vers 1000 personnes
c'est énorme pour la nouvelle calédonie
là j'avais d'ailleurs dit que ce qui se
passait dans sur ce territoire était
totalement contraire aux lois de la
république tout le monde devrait rendre
des comptes j'ai même menacé le
président n'aurait plus d'autre coup et
c'est là où je m'étais exclamé devant
cette assistance
j'ai dit si je suis ici c'est parce que
la france est une et indivisible et que
la défense de bastia commence à nous
mais ça avait été du délire
le le sénat ne peut vraiment jouer un
rôle politique que lorsqu'il est dans
l'opposition au pouvoir
si la majorité du sénat et de la même
couleur que le pouvoir en place
la marge de manoeuvre dont tu tombes
dont ils disposent n'est pas très grave
il lui reste à la capacité habituelle
qui consiste à demander les textes etc
mais les grands débats politiques non
nous refusons les âmes